[Music]
should i factor our snowshoes
what people do that you know fun fact
not only is it the oldest but remains
one of the most effective means of
traversing the ice
wow yeah you're gonna fit right in at
beaverfield
everything here is a little
[Music]
questionable ranger the people
the weather everything
[Music]
oh creature
you look like you just ain't a corpse
well the roads are
out and something's wrong with the
generator which generator
all of them thinking on the internet uh
also there's a dead body under your
[Applause]
porch
[Applause]
probably a wolf what are you like a wolf
detective no marcus
who knows who
he's gonna kill next
i think we can all agree that it's
unsafe outside their safety in numbers
out of curiosity who is packing
well we're having a good old-fashioned
sleepover with guns though with guns yes
everything about this predator is
unorthodox it's not a human
it's not canine it's one of them
one of what i like a what
a werewolf what could have gotten in
here
how did they get out
he says he got out
[Laughter]
maybe i'm a werewolf maybe you're a
werewolf
maybe you're a werewolf you're aware of
your way off
are we really in a mexican standoff
right now baby don't say mexican
just stand up
[Applause]
you know we're probably just gonna head
out please just pull it
out
please
please don't bother the luck i could
have gotten
[Music]
you